is the best i have ever heard and uh
that's really good
so we thought how do you take that to
the next level
uh and and here's how oh you have
charles barkley interview charles
barkley
uh danny rouye joins us
[Music]
and i'm looking forward to chuck
interviewing chuck
this is a great pla first of all it's a
pleasure to have me here
it's an honor like i say i've been doing
this for many years
and i've been doing i've been doing this
for very long and it's good to be
appreciated
i was listening to y'all talk before i
came on the air and we didn't win as
many awards as we should have
i'm spending some industry secrets back
to you ernie
what you got for the trunkster what are
you what have you always wanted to know
well this is this first question for
chuck this is chuck i want to ask you
first of all like i say
uh how come when it's your turn to talk
you put your right hand down on the
podium like this embrace yourself like
it's an earthquake why you do that
you have to speak with power you have to
speak with conviction
let people know you in the room so you
do put your hand down
to get their attention first and
foremost that didn't make no sense now
here's my next question for chuck this
is also chuck
when is kenneth turn the talk earn the
throw to kenneth so ernie got the ball
it's
not a real ball but it's a it's a potent
ball and he threw it to kenny
why come does it look like first like i
say that kenny
looks like he's about to give toddler
bad news why does he have that pain
expression on his face when it's his
time
i can answer that go ahead go ahead back
to you
because hey hey chuck because every time
you ask me a question chuck
i have to hear it like first of all
and it's not really first of all yeah
it's usually second of all a third of
all a fourth of all a fifth of all
so he's always using the same one as
it's the first time we're hearing it and
it's not
that's why i'm in the painful look that
makes sense
see how that answer makes sense first of
all
can it make it first of all here it is
first of all there it is
there it is first of all stay in
character daddy stay in character
that's right first of all go ahead first
of all what
i'm saying you you make sense ernie
makes sense and i make sense
that's the way this show works what
about shaq don't don't make no sense
i don't need to i'll make dollars and
cents
go ahead chuck oh very good thank you
very much so this is a chunk again for
chuck
my question is how come every time
there's a highlight and there's a center
not even in the game but in this in the
arena maybe he hurt his street clothes
how come shaq take credit for the center
he didn't invent the position but he act
like he do how come he do that
thank you danny thank you very much and
he can't give no big man no credit
well let me answer that okay because i'm
the reigning dundata of all big men
period that's why i can speak on that if
you don't like it do something about it
chip
i'll come to washington dc and get some
furniture moving down there
[Laughter]
well so hold on hold on so this happened
today on on twitter
shaq was on twitter he issued a
challenge he said to me
he said any punk can do with charles
brock i don't think that's true i think
mine's very good
but he said anybody can do charles but
can people do shaq
so i'd like to do a joke between shaq
and charles if that's okay
let me ask you shut up let me ask you
something knock knock chuck
i don't want to have a knock knock joke
with you dumb it no no chuck five who's
there
a second trip to the finals a second
never mind wrong house
you see what i did again
that was good thank you
thank you chuck i have other questions
about
um it's basically about your guarantees
do you think it's important to ever get
a guarantee right
no no just just
[Music]
[Music]
hey danny you see what you started there
that's the right answer
my last question is if bojan bogdanovic
and bogdan bogdanovic
were to fight for bogdanovic supremacy
who would win
the big buck donovich which one's that
big pun
but you said bobon right
uh wait utah the utah bogdanovic or the
atlanta
oh i love atlanta bogdanovic i'm going
with the atlanta back donovich
that's also correct hey
danny uh thank you can we hear your
regular voice how could you say that
really i actually got to forget how to
do my regular voice guys i sort of
i've been doing this for a whole bunch
of days but uh
this is a pleasure uh you guys are the
best show ever so thank you for having
me man
great job thank you for having fun with
us brother continued success
thank you hit a grant for us all right
man thank you so much
awesome that was fun now that was uh
that was different who else
he said uh who works with work him you
know chris miles
yeah yeah he says from nba tv yes
uh ernie question yes it was funny him
or the german dude von bravanovich
um what's his name pep pepper good
different yeah yeah they're pretty close
but in terms of a chuck impersonation
that was good
hope to get any better than that that's
a wrap for the knights inside the nba
presented by kia